remaniement ministériel aujourd'hui à
queen's park à toronto rob ford va donc
procéder à ce mouvement de chaises tout
ça a été causé par le départ du ministre
du développement économique
un vétéran jim morrison ça a été annoncé
vendredi soir geneviève tellier
professeur spécialiste de politique
ontarienne à l'université d'ottawa
bonjour ateliers alors je disais tu
auras john molson s'est depuis les
années depuis l'année 98 je pense qu'il
est à queen's park est ce que c'était
est-ce que c'était véritablement un
pilier de par son rôle de par sa place
dans le parti
oui puis non oui parce que ce parti qui
manque beaucoup d'expérience en fait
pour le parti mais l'équipe de monsieur
fall a commencé par se faire lui-même
qui avait pas vraiment d'expérience
politique sur la scène provinciale et
donc lui connu les airs harry se posera
plus dans les années 90 où il y avait
beaucoup de changements sur la scène
politique et donc c'était le seul de ces
années là qu'ils étaient encore en phase
et monsieur x de besoin un peu de cette
expérience là justement comme je disais
avec plus au monde d'une expérience lui
même alors c'est quand même un gros
morceau tu quittes le cabinet ouais mais
le développement économique faut penser
que l'ontario a été de la difficulté je
pense à s'en sortir économiquement la
satire un peu de la patte
oui le québec s'y faire une comparaison
le québec est en position enviable sur
le quota à l'ontario vendredi il y avait
monsieur wilson aux côtés de monsieur x
qui avaient commencé à dévoiler ses
fameuse pancarte je pense qu'ils vous
rappeler en campagne électorale ça avait
été promis qu on allait mettre des gros
signaux des grosses point car le long
des routes à la frontière avec les états
unis et 10 en ontario aux open for
business alors on est ouvert pour faire
des affaires
c'est une promesse électorale donc c'est
surprenant de voir que monsieur wilson
était là vendredi avec monsieur foé des
querelles quelques jours quelques heures
plus tard on apprend qu'il quitte le non
seulement cabinet mais le caucus c'est à
dire qu'il n'est plus député
conservateur et n'est plus député
conservateur alors comment saura plus au
cours des prochaines heures mais mais ce
qui me surprend aussi c'est que pour un
poste de ministre ça va toucher six
ministres alors quoi déjà après quatre
mois il était tard déplacés déjà
exactement
on n'est pas vraiment au courant que ça
allait si mal que ça c'est un nouveau
gouvernement s'attend à ce qu'elle
quelques petites anicroches
là encore de plus du quart du caucus du
cabinet qui changent alors comme il
s'agit un peu la chaise musicale mais
aussi j'espère qu'on va en savoir un peu
plus aujourd'hui les raisons de ces
changements là dans certains cas il ya
eu des d'émotion une députés 1 ministre
monsieur thibault l'eau qui avait un peu
un passé douteux effectivement procom
fracturé la couronne s'était question
vous vous questionnez sa présence est
terminée mais pour les autres ce sera
intéressant de savoir la raison pourquoi
il ya eu ce changement ce jeu de chaises
musicales bon parlez nous un peu là
après quatre mois du genre de bilan
comment il est toujours perçue par la
population par les électeurs ontariens
me chiffonne c'est vrai que c'est pas
mal la même chose qu'au moment des
élections c'est à dire qu'il ya une
partie de l'électorat qui est tout à
fait d'accord avec ces politiques sont
au chamboule un peu ce qui se passe pas
c'est justement à la saga avec le
conseil municipal à toronto où on le
réduit on aime des choses qui bougent
béton m brasse un peu la cage et donc
s'appelait une partie de l'électorat
la question du sida taxe sur le carbone
ce sera un autre dossier qui a été
repris par contre pour d'autres c'est
l'insatisfaction comme on l'avait prévu
il ya beaucoup de manifestations
publiques dans les rues par exemple
l'abolition de la rose salaire minimum à
15 $ ça ne plaît pas le changement
d'éducation du cours d'éducation
sexuelle
donc c'est disais je voudrais aussi la
population est sensiblement la même
chose que ce qu'on voyait durant la
campagne électorale et hollandais du la
formation du cabinet va très bien merci
beaucoup de votre perspective là dessus
comme telle et à la prochaine
merci au revoir